lectures on succinct arguments shortly
what they are and in the afternoon we
will discuss zero knowledge proof okay
so the plan for today is rather simple
first step to tell you what our
arguments okay yeah then I wanna a
motivate why we should study arguments
as opposed to say proofs explain a
difference in a moment and the reason is
that they can be succinct and that's a
good thing okay and then I will get into
the technical part to the talk which is
you know how do we construct 16
arguments okay once again I will you
know even though is your knowledge and
succinctness are great together will
really not discuss your knowledge this
morning this will be mostly left to the
afternoon em alright so explain what is
an argument I have to first recall you
what is a proof okay so here's a review
from yesterday morning and also today
will be mostly working with languages
that have witnesses so to make it easier
to talk about them I'll just really talk
about relations so hey remember that
relation is a set of pairs where you
have an axe as your instance W is your
witness okay for example X could be a
boolean formula and W would be the
corresponding corresponding satisfying
assignment okay yeah when I say the
language for the relation I really mean
all instances for which there is a
witness okay
and yesterday we saw the notion of an
interactive proof that I'll sometimes
they're not just IP which is a pair of
probe listicle another time Interactive
algorithms they prove are in the
verifier denoted P and V for which you
have two properties okay the first
property is completeness
okay it says that for every pair in the
relation if you hand this pair to the
prover and you just give the instance to
the verifier and they talk okay at the
end of the interaction the verifier says
i'm convinced with rubb ility one also i
added here a security parameter
yesterday was a question about what
happens to a kind of the error for the
proof system in general you can think
about that what the polygon the verifier
have secure security parameter like
lambda that controls the other
case right soundness right in this case
here when the instance happens to not be
in the language of the relation then no
matter which prove er is showing up to
talk with the very fire the very fiery
will make sure that he's convinced with
probability at most you know some error
that you know it should go down very
fast the security parameter so if you
think about this error to be something
like you know 2 to the minus lambda okay
so this is we've seen yesterday some
constructions of interactive proofs most
notably the Sun check protocol okay and
today we want to talk about arguments so
what is the main difference between an
argument and a proof is that we are
going to make a tiny change in the
definition and specifically we're going
to consider a relaxation of the
soundness property so it's called you
know two prime here and we're gonna call
this computational soundness denote the
fact that we are going to require
security or you know some nests only
against rumors that are efficient so
what is efficient mean precisely well it
depends there's a number of ways you can
formalize it in a uniform computational
model you can just say it is a probably
stick paternal time algorithm you could
also consider non-uniform computational
models and say it's a family of Polly on
all sides circuits okay so but roughly
speaking it means that computationally
bounded in some way okay typically in
time resources a as opposed to an
interactive proof where it really could
be unbound unbounded in any resource
okay so the first point that I want to
make is so regarding what their
arguments is that name as well here so
now we're looking at argument and let's
say it's ia right so interactive
arguments relaxed interactive proofs
okay so it's just relaxation yes
was actually already such in the prior
definition just happens to be the case
that there is a since you anyways
maximizing over all such provers the
provers might as well have the best coin
tosses and a fixed sort of in its heart
and here it depends on which
computational model you consider for
example with polynomial size circuits
you could in general just fix the best
but in general yeah you can just think
about it the probability is over the
space of randomness for the prover and
the verifier
so interactive arguments relax
other acts Interactive groups okay it's
important to realize that relax this
relaxation is meaningful right
so it's true that we are syntactically
saying well it's a it is easier to
achieve an interactive argument and it
is the Chiva interactive proof simply
because interactive proof is an
interactive argument okay so maybe let's
put it in a set theoretic picture here
is the set of interactive proofs and it
is contained in a set of interactive
arguments okay relaxation in that you
have more such objects okay it's
important to realize realize that the
relaxation is meaningful what is
meaningful me means that anyways in the
real world during applications we are
rarely confronted with unbounded
adversary's you know quite the contrary
usually we are confronted with bounded
adversary's this is analogous to you
know many other similar relaxations we
make in computer science all the time
maybe a very sort of notable one is when
we relaxed the notion of information
theoretic encryption you know Shannon
like to computational notions like
semantic security so that we can
actually do so all right so that's the
definition is actually pretty simple a
now we want to ask why studied them
right so in general just like with
encryption we relaxed
information theoretic security to
computational security because we can do
more okay now we want a sort of a
try to sharpen what is it that we
couldn't do with interactive proofs that
we would like to do now with arguments
[Music]
the answer should be not you know
because proofs of limitations right and
I want to first highlight you know one
such limitation okay so example let's
consider a the sat relation so what is
it well it's just you have I which is a
boolean formula so it Maps say n bits to
1 bit a NWO is the witness so it's an
assignment to the N variables of the
formula that makes the formula true so
let's focus for a moment in this
relation and let's consider kind of the
trivial proof system for sat where the
prover sends the witness to the very
fire which X so in this case the
communication complexity is n bits right
because we're just sending the witness
right this is a proof system because by
definition if
if the formula is satisfiable then
increase the witness that the prover can
send and if it's not then there isn't a
witness that the prover consent that
will make the very fire except let's ask
a basic question you know could it be
that there is some way to convince the
verifier using either a non interactive
or interactive proof by sending less
than n bits okay
so could it be the interactive proof
save us in communication okay so we'd
like something like you know some
conversation possibly using some check
or you know some other you know sneaky
little extensions like we saw yesterday
something something sort of non trivial
that makes you verifier a except when by
satisfiable and reject with high
probability when it's not and the
communication you say much much less
than n Sigma for example square root of
n ok so that would be nice yeah even
before thinking about this question
let's think about here do we would we
expect maybe something slightly
non-trivial you know some proof may be
smarter
smaller than n beats could you expect
something like that it's a non
rhetorical question would you believe
that would expect that it is possible to
have just non interactive proof where I
send some string less than n bits right
clearly if I send the witness and those
are n bits right so maybe I can do
something else altogether just very
different one message that consists
considers for example square root of n
bits
is that something would expect it will
also be a witness and in particular yeah
exactly and so we have a sort of ways to
capture this intuition that sat is to
Tony and hard we have things for example
like the exponential time hypothesis ok
it's not quite applicable here because
the verifier maybe could flip coins
so really exponential time hypothesis
talks about deterministic time but we do
believe that you know Sat is kind of 2
to the N heart right and if we had some
way to send less than an information
sake where root of n then we could just
go over all the proofs and check them
right and that would mean that would
imply some probabilistic algorithm that
runs into to the root n time for solving
shot ok so this is something we can't
expect here ok so expect sides would
prove to be say root or little o n if we
believe sat is 2 to D Omega n hard ok
and again here there is some really need
to be a little bit precise here because
we're talking about probabilistic time
ok but it's just a non interactive proof
right maybe we can do something smart
across multiple messages ok well out
here could we expect something square
root and communication maybe over a
logarithmic number of rounds or
something like that that's clear right
because you know if you think about all
the possibilities it's a tree that
potentially maybe can't control or it's
hard to think about
yeah we're not gonna think about it
online yep yes the verifier is bounded
and you know maybe if it's runs in more
time we could figure out the statement
that was sent was not it can be turned
into proof so I'll tell you what are the
circumcisions that you need to take into
account to turn it into proof one is the
running time well you know the verify
was running in polynomial time so maybe
it's not such a big consideration more
importantly is the randomness complexity
or the verifier so you cannot in general
run over all the possible settings of
the random tape of a probabilistic
polynomial-time algorithm what you can
do though is to approximate its
acceptance probability and because you
have a you will have a constant gap
between yes and no then you can in
polynomial time sort of decide the
difference and then you can basically
say the algorithm is as follows you loop
over all the possible proofs and for
each proof you approximate the decision
probability of the verifier using
sampling a good question so ok will not
get into the actual argument but let me
say that you know there is a theorem
it's very nice paper by Golder can
hosted 98 that says that even with
multiple rounds
you can't expect much in fact there is a
general result that says that if you
have interactive proof for a relation R
with communication C okay then you can
decide our
in two to the OFC times
poly a probabilistic time okay so this
kind of go over all the possibilities
can carries over in some indirect way
also to the case of a tree essentially
is the fact that the depth of the tree
is not very much right it's polynomial
adapt deep ok the fan out because it's
bounded in communication is also not
very large so it costs you like to do
this see to explore it and the main
technicality is precisely having to do
with randomness you can own it up you
cannot actually materialize the whole
tree because they fan out from the
prover from the very fire moves is very
big because it can have potentially a
lot of randomness but the fact that the
small communication is they can actually
approximate it reasonably well ok so
this is telling us that for any relation
in particular for the sat relation if we
have C in communication complexity that
we can decide in 2 to the order of C and
so if we believe that sat is 2 to the
order of n hard we also cannot expect an
interactive proof that saves us in
communication over say the trivial proof
ok this all to say is that interactive
proofs are quite limited when it comes
to discussing non-deterministic
languages or like communicating witness
they don't say viewing communication
complexity there so there are other
limitations you can talk about free
interactive proofs but this is the one I
want to highlight now so now the both
arguments the one that we discussed and
the one already both running out of
English words a with strategy is to
prove this statements really apply to
proofs if you kind of try to go through
that strategy in the argument case ok it
just doesn't go through ok so this
leaves open the door of maybe we can
have arguments do something great for us
for example maybe convincing a verifier
that our formula is satisfiable by
communicating on a logarithmic
it's okay it'll be nice so this is wanna
what I wanna sort of formalize next I
want to put down the goal of a sixteenth
argument okay so yes it's a it's very
good question the question is am i
bounding communication just from proving
to verifier or also from very far to
prove er if you look in this paper there
are four different theorems consider a
number of considerations you know is
your interactive proof public point or
not and are you in a bounding only one
direction or the other right now the
particular statement that I have here
considers communication that is bounded
in both directions if you bound only one
direction kind of this thing gets a
little bit more messy so if you if you
care yeah thank you well if you care
specifically about one direction then
the state of the art is actually not in
this paper there's a there's a follow up
follow up then you can simulate in :
deterministic time to do the oopsie
which effectively says the same
effectively means the same conclusion
that it's unlikely to have laconic
non-trivial electronic oops considering
only over to very far community thank
you okay so why star the arguments
because proofs of limitations okay so
now let's talk about a
what are cooking we are means so hmm
we're gonna take a step back and instead
of talking about the specific sat
relation we're gonna consider a kind of
universal relation or relation that
talks about all satisfiability problems
kind of together okay yeah so let's call
this relation R star okay eat the
instances in our star are consist of
triples actually it's a you can think
about it as an algorithm or a program an
input and a time bound so that's kind of
your X I don't have a weakness okay and
instant sweetness is in the relation R
star if the algorithm or program accepts
the input Z and weakness tab will you in
at most T steps so if for example you
want to express the sat relation through
this language well what you do is you
consider Z to be the formula at hand
okay you would set a to be the program
that given a formula in a weakness we'll
just check it satisfiability so this is
kind of like a general a language for
all satisfiability problems okay you can
think about it this is just you know
non-deterministic time right yes again I
am really specific it's kind of her
program right something I give you a
specific program and a specific input
right and I'm asking for this program is
specific input that is there a weakness
that makes the program accept at most T
steps now you can recover relations such
as sat by considering the same program
and different inputs okay so you can fix
you know the program a sat right that
we'll consider as input things that look
like that
and it will sort of and for the same
program you can also consider a you know
different early a different so you can
also put stupid programs that are
completely uninteresting yeah so it's a
universal so it includes intelligent
problems and stupid problems so yeah
teas and give is very important that tea
is given in binary and I'll get to that
later so the size of tea is log T it
will be very important right now because
I'm gonna define a succeed argument so
I'm gonna say an interactive argument or
our star is succinct if two conditions
hold the weight before we get to these
two conditions when I when I when I say
the phrase interactive argument for our
star I'm already inheriting the
completeness and soundness properties
for interactive argument for the
specific relation our star right so I
don't need to write them again
now instead I'm going to talk about
these deficiency properties that comfort
with succinctness we actually use a and
B instead of a one and two one is that
the communication complexity is small
how small
well Paulie in the security parameter
which generally you cannot avoid and the
logarithm on the running time okay
so it's kind of if you think about this
this is essentially exponentially small
than so we'll come back to the we'll
come back to that in a moment let me
first write down the properties
Commission effectively small and the
verification time is also small small
well I would like to write the same
expression but for the verifier can't
quite right to the same expression can
anybody say cy
really right again poly lambda and log T
as the read the input right so at the
very least I should be nice enough and
let the verifier read the instance that
is checking so we will Poli in the
description of the program okay in the
size of its input in would not have to
change the simplex before right so
before you head just like you could talk
about just succinct in terms of
communication and you're making yeah
because let me maybe so succinctness is
a rather yes fluid the notion sometimes
people care about this something scared
people I'll put this and that or even
relaxations they're off so any
non-trivial communication complexity
over say the size of the weakness is
generally like a good good thing so you
will if you can consult the literature
to change names will be used for a
number of these
different goals about either
communication alone or both
communication of verification time this
specific ones are to some extent a very
extreme settings with these parameters
and the reason why I'm putting them down
is because they are achieved by the
classical constructions they will
discuss things that achieve this how
would you describe something like bullet
points yeah there are you know I guess
office jargon that I don't know if it's
worthy of a you know being enshrined in
terminology but at least in my head a
these two properties
I like to think about it as you know
either proof or or communication
succinct sixteenth is kind of a misnomer
because it's an was an argument okay but
and the other one is kind of
verification sixteen to verifier
succinct the point being is that you
know if you qualify the objective
succinct then you denote which thing
ought to be small in general of course
if you say that this is small this can't
be too big either right so this is a
slightly stronger goal okay up to the
fact that here you have some parameters
that you know we don't usually appear I
I think this taxonomy of different
notion succinctness will become
necessarily explicit in the first
workshop at the end of September simply
because there are many works that
explore different trade-offs here for
today I want to try to mostly keep it
under the carpet because we'll discuss
only one construction that achieves this
specific setting of parameters which is
a rather a demanding setting drafters
[Music]
that is correct yes this is for our star
and then for every every sort of tuple
in in our star this is what you want to
achieve this basically says you get to
read the input okay but not much more
that's a very fire and this says that
you you know your scent you know
exponentially fewer bits than a
retrieval system to put this in pictures
kind of the picture you should have in
mind is that there is a big hockey
prover that gets as input so the
instance in the witness and and that is
this tiny tiny
interaction with a tiny very fire a that
only gets as input the instance okay so
I'm using X instead of Z sorry
and this should be compared against kind
of the trivial proof system where the
trooper a that's the same the same
inputs but all it does it it sends W
which could be enormous right I mean W
could be upwards of size T and the very
fire has to read it all and check it by
running that computation it's like a bit
of a stupid proof system at the point is
that kind of you have this exponential
reduction in communication and
verification time okay so it's kind of
what succinctness okay so you're just
trying to say like some computation at
this point it is not justified it is I
find it more natural but you could
consider that a comes with Z hard-coded
in it for actual constructions actually
it is helpful to be hey to treat a and Z
separately because sometimes you can
play some tricks well first they're
different time complexity associated to
a and Z okay and second sometimes you
can have tricks around pre-processing
we're kind of for the same a you do some
computation that across different Z's
you benefit from and then also just the
analogy to Sat I find it more explicit
because you fix this at program and a
stat program kind of looks at the
particular instance for today and it's
easier to recover specific and P NP
relations this way so I find it slightly
more natural if you have some randomness
you have to put it here so in general
you cannot be exponential because
then it will take more than 30 min we
have to be left with W HC W at least a
is to with W a well in here yes but not
here right so at the point so that a in
an argument system for our star the
verifier only receives as input the
instance which is a Z and T okay T is in
binary okay
so T could be exponentially bigger than
well it is exponentially bigger than its
representation so in particular the
verifier by running in this time could
run exponentially faster than the
witness sighs okay so sorry all right
make sure you're simply you're saying
that this has to work for all a for
which you have a true theorem right for
example if a decides not to halt then
the prover will not be in a position to
prove any theories again through any
true theorem right so like if you have
some input on which a does something
that is any interesting in particular
maybe doesn't halt but then you will
have just not a true theorem that you
can prove things about but you have to
specify which Z right so if you yeah if
you bring a Z to the table and you know
come concrete time bound for which a is
doing is accepting for some W then then
then sure you can you can do that what
you're saying but the pre-processing
which usually you want to do it on
things like side or something better
that pre person also has to work on this
year
functions yeah at the end of a day
because this is universal the machinery
will be brought to bear will barely
interpret what is inside a it will treat
it as a universal machine of some sort
so ok now as abstract as this sounds the
guarantees are also useful in a sense
that even as we speak you know there are
atheneum contracts that are deployed on
some test nets that implement a verifier
and benefit from the exponential savings
overnight native computation so these
are things that despite sort of this you
know rather abstract nature in the
anyway they be precisely because
language is universal you can you know
put in it you know problems of interest
and benefit from exponential savings in
running time okay okay so I'll try to
keep this here it's definitional 16th
arguments and I want a transition to
constructing them okay for questions
about the definition motivation T to be
at most n to see I haven't really been
precise about the the against what
provers do I want to be secure against
so Barak and Roderick say they
specifically wanted T to be potentially
in super super polynomial not not quite
it depends sort of haven't really know
quantified things against T right the
universal I which allows you to be on
the same size as a
yeah but the question is you know when I
come back here and express it through
here do I put any any bounds on T for
example do I want
do I want to restrict T to be Paulie and
in arbitrary polynomial in the security
parameter so that would for example
address this consideration and maybe let
me say explicitly I'm right now I'm for
simplicity I'm assuming that T is always
taken to be some arbitrary polygon and a
security parameter so that I don't have
to worry about you know so literally
exponential like something super
polynomial though there are technical
ways to handle the complexity leveraging
some things that are you know slightly
above super polynomial for example let's
say that I in the security proofs that I
will show today
yes yes
is there a restriction a sense that yeah
this is more of a technicality it's it's
not really necessary even for the
constructions I will discuss you can
actually sort of you can with the right
setting with secure perimeter you can
actually scale up well beyond and peep
all the way up to next yes rather lock
lock T is over lambda so I want locti to
be oval amiright binary thing was
confusing at least me so the running
time of the computation is some
polynomial in the security parameter
okay and this is not necessary but is
very many constructions require it not
all and certainly it is it is a cozy
feeling to think that
all right
I'm tempted to delete this one I think
who are comfortable with it while I'm
deleting is just the definition of an
interactive argument remember just like
an interactive proof but soundness is
computational
so now we get to three how to construct
there's actually a long answer okay
there are many many beautiful and
different constructions of 16th
arguments and I think many of them will
be displayed either through seminars
here or the first workshop today
specifically will focus on one okay it's
a kind of the first such construction
it's a classical construction
communities due to Joe Killian okay so
specifically I will see how to a
transform any through PCP with you know
good enough parameters we'll come back
to that in a moment into a succinct
argument
so this is a construction mm so we had
two lectures on PCPs
yesterday I just remind you of you a
picture how they look like okay and that
would be enough for our use today
because we're mostly using them we'll be
using them as a black box starting point
is that is a theorem actually the very
same paper that Prahlad discussed
yesterday and gave sort of a taste of
the construction that essentially you
know in in this language or rather in
this terminology you could basically say
that our star has with PCP is okay so
what does it mean so let's put on a
picture of how what does good mean so
you have a PCP prover that will spit out
a long proof I'll just you denoted
capital PI just you know it's big the
prover you know in this case will take
as input a ZT and W okay the proof will
sigh will be will have size that is
polity in fact an instruction I mean for
today it will suffice to have polity but
the particular construction can get you
you know something pretty close to
something something like T to the 1 plus
epsilon and this thing can be checked
they by a very fire that again gates it
gets as input just the instance okay in
Paulie yeah I'm gonna add a security
parameter here because we're building
some cryptographic construction so we
look here about the security parameter
for the lying PCP thus allosteric for
the underlying PCP to it decent
so the verifier will have a running time
the depends on on a security parameter
and then just like in a succinct a
chance extinct argument to learn
polynomial in its input okay this is
just the size with input this is the
security parameter what about the
running time of the prover changes
slightly larger gun to output all these
things so what I meant by good here
is specifically just saying that you
know the proof is not too big the time
to generate it is not too big and
crucially the running time of the
verifier is actually small and maybe you
know I want to put separately that
number of queries that we're making is
Polly okay so what you saw yesterday as
a sort of high-level construction or PCP
basically gets you all these parameters
maybe the one thing that we didn't
discuss you know very carefully
yesterday's like how do you make sure
the verifier runs fast yeah but you know
we can't do everything two hours right
so so for now we're going to take this
as a given this is a starting point and
this picture is all we're gonna need for
today okay we're happy with it so does
the PCP just a long proof that can be
realistically checked we're asking a
small number of queries and running fast
now all these under light blue things
are very reminiscent of our efficiency
goals over there
so maybe it's not surprising that an
object like this one has something to do
with a construction 16 arguments in fact
in fact let's try to do that let's try
to the first attempt okay it's gonna be
you know a bit silly but I think it's
important to go through it so first
attempt at what we want to try to
construct a single argument from this
PCP so let's say that the prover I'm not
gonna keep writing the inputs very far
so now we have the prover in a verifier
for the argument system and suppose that
the first natural attempt will be to be
something like this sample the
randomness are for V PCP so this is the
succinct argument verifier samples
randomness for the PCP verifier it sends
it to the ruler the prover it produces
the PCP how it well just invokes the PCP
prove Iran the relevant inputs
it reduces the query set implied by that
randomness for this proof it returns the
proof on that query set this is a small
number of queries and the verifier will
decide according to running VP CP not
only hole proof but on the particular
view of it that was sent but that's okay
because it's running it in the same
randomness so essentially what this per
this protocol attempt is saying you want
to construct 1/16 argument why not tell
the argument verify to send over which
randomness heap ones plans to use the
prover will just produce the proof this
deduce which part of the proof the
verifier is interested in and shipped
back just the answers to the queries
that were made according to this
randomness and in the verifier can then
run its decision procedure before we get
to the security which is turns out it's
questionable
are we happy syntactically what this
protocol is saying on a particular
randomness and really input the verifier
has a particular view it says or is
interests in a particular view on this
randomness it says I want to look at
locations 5 10 and 12 now the prover
input might in principle would have been
happy to send the entire proof but
remember the proof is big polity so
that's going to be way over budget for
us no we want Poli Lochte
on across different random strings but
for this particular random string it's
looking specifically at this query set
so I'm sending just that essentially
what you're saying is we're asking the
prover to sample the proof for us okay
with the randomness that I care about
today right
why because you really can't send the
whole proof it's too long okay
realistically shockable proofs are long
proofs that can be sampled okay doesn't
mean the short proof right so it's in
tactically okay with this protocol all
right now let's get to security or even
arrest me to talk about efficiency first
like this satisfies the properties of
16th argument from an efficiency
perspective the randomness is small I
didn't say that here but it's you know
poly log T this is gonna be a log T okay
what is the verifier doing with sampling
some randomness are running a PCP
verifier so certainly is gonna be fast
right but I claim there is some rather
glaring issues in security here what
could the prover do to make to make the
very fire except even when it shouldn't
really I didn't really talk about the
randomness complexity here but you know
thank you Mohammed maybe I should say
that you are should also be alarmed and
log T again the reason why not really
highlighting like just all natural
constructions like have this property
since I'm sending the randomness what is
the issue in security here the
randomness was random because it should
have been right so if you send the
randomness here then the prover can just
pick the answers to the Animus to to
make the very far except it's like
saying let's I don't know bet on a coin
flip and your bet comes after the coin
flip lands right come on like how you
that's not how the coin flip is random
right if it comes after and you know the
outcome right and then you can bet
accordingly so similarly here the
soundness of a PCP crucially relies on
the fact that first you write down the
proof now it's there then you sample the
randomness for the queries okay anything
this you have soundness properties here
a you can't trust the prover to think in
his mind a proof and not change it when
it sees the randomness certainly won't
do that but a more indirect way to to
see that there's something wrong with
this protocol is the fact that there's
no cryptography here everything is
information theoretic and we know that
we're not supposed to go anywhere with
information theoretic objects through
these limitations
okay so cryptography must come in
somewhere okay so I know it's bit us to
be protocol but you know it's important
to realize that the randomness must come
after the proof
were stupid one is that the true virtues
are more stupid one is the arch Bluebird
chooses our and then sends directly that
would be like a non-interactive yes but
you know exactly as as stupid as this
protocol is it kind of crystallizes the
main issue is that we want the prover to
commit to the proof okay that's exactly
how we're gonna fix it and so that's why
you know this is my opinion Killian
spiracle is really beautiful because
it's a really really really simple
construction of 16th argument yeah once
you have hidden all the PCP machinery
away into like a nice picture okay so
now let's fix this Perico
so we better attempt would be to make
the approver commit to hi first and only
then send okay and we'll be using
cryptography for committing now this
something that to be still said here you
know how are we gonna commit to this
long string right for example we just
think in terms of photography for
moments they say that I use Chateau 56
okay to commit to PI if I just kind of
hash it like normally later like how do
i commit to it for you right so I have
to somehow use a particular way of
committing to this long PI such that
later I can reveal to you small bits and
pieces of it right
so this calls to arms are very important
sort of data structure or paradigm
computer science which is a what Merkle
trees right so I assume that everybody
has heard what is a miracle tree but who
has seen a miracle tree okay so I'm not
going to go through it right so we're
gonna be using a miracle tree and
specifically the main property we need
is so we actually don't need in this
case a general purpose cryptographic
hash function it will suffice to have
one that has the property of collision
resistance okay so just to remind you
you know what collision resistance means
since simply because we'll be using it
later so you know have a hash function
family
so what does this mean it means that you
know we have a family of distributions
over hashes one per security parameter
is collision resistant if for every
efficient that guy a tilde to be
distinguished from the algorithm a which
the probability for a random hash
function sampled from HK that
we had verse three outputs to a kind of
pre images given the description of a
hash function and these are different
but collide is so-called negligible in a
security parameter which means like it
vanishes faster than the inverse of any
polynomial okay so is it just for those
of you that maybe haven't seen what
collision resistance means it's you know
we can be written down as a formal
definition here it is and you can build
a miracle tree using this particularly
any any hash function and in this perk
will be using just this property
sometimes you use other properties of
hash functions so let's write down the
protocol and the first thing that the
very very fire is going to do it's going
to sample the hash function description
and it will say to the prover please use
this particular hash function to build
your miracle tree maybe just to
understand why is it even a distribution
of our hash functions because if you fix
a particular hash function a particular
prover attacking you may have been born
with collisions in its heart right so
somehow you want to defeat these kind of
pre-computer collisions by sampling the
hash function yourself
so now the prover knows which hash
function it should be using so let's see
there's no randomness yet about the PCP
right so the probe will produce the PCP
using a PCP ruler and it will commit to
the PCP and let's say you know it kind
of computes the root which is you know
some miracle tree procedure or depends
on age it says here's the root of the
miracle tree that I've thought about
today okay so the verifier for now
pockets the root it's just waiting for
later and now it's samples the
randomness now it sends it okay the
proven now can deduce the query set Q
for this randomness and it also computes
or you know prepares know computes this
is called authentication paths for the
locations what this mean it means that Q
will determine certain locations in the
proof and the prover will just assemble
the authentication paths that certify or
the reveal that sort of authenticate
each of these locations against the root
so in replying it will say here are the
answers in PI sub Q
I restrict to the cue and here the paths
and now the number of paths is also
fixed somewhere before or there will be
a at least in the simplest construction
one path per query because in the tree
so once you have a leaf you look at the
subway the path is like the co path
right it's kind of all the siblings of
everything on from you to the to the
route and this would be a list of paths
one per query and prayer answered query
there and now so you basically check the
ads with respect to the route that you
received earlier and the query set Q
which you can compute yourself and then
like before now you can decide according
to that very fire
maybe Sydney Wiese restricted a few and
then you provide all the inputs
I think you know some of you have seen
this Perot called many many times so but
I some haven't
and it is a beautiful protocol okay if
you sort of wondering how you construct
a sixteenth argument it's actually
really simple you just start with any
PCP right and you do this commit first
and reveal later paradigm okay in this
way
you're basically harnessing the
probabilistically checkable nature of
this long proofs and you're turning them
into like sort of sixteen arguments
because you never actually have to send
this long proof it's only materialized
in the head of the prover hey now what I
want to do right now is what we're gonna
do a after the break is that I actually
want to go ahead and try to analyze this
there's something interesting in
something certainly the intuition is
strong for what this program makes sense
but when I do try to analyze it it's a
rather simple proof but it is some
slightly non-trivial realizations in the
proof that I want to try to highlight
okay and and then we'll do we'll discuss
how this 16th argument can actually be
made non-interactive which is the neural
activity non interactivity of student
argument is something you know really
well motivated in the lot change that in
green which is one of the
if the PCP is that at least we saw
yesterday we're very very generous about
the size of the proof yes if you
Knothole take a you know path in America
three routes are very very long proof
you'll end up with something linear if
you're to be it would be still
logarithmic right because whatever well
in the exponential site you would yeah
you would not be using an exponential
size like X patine that would be bad and
this construction cannot harness that
though interestingly there are other
constructions that use different type of
cryptography that can harness those type
of exponential size PCP is because they
use the linear structure without
materializing the whole evaluation table
so in general most interesting PCP is
even if they're not quite sort of a sort
of standard setting of parameters lead
to some type of 16th argument you just
need to bring to bear the right
cryptography actually it's a very it's a
surprisingly interconnected and a dense
area of ideas that it's this interplay
between information theoretic
non-trivial results about checking
computation and then corresponding
implications to cryptography it's kind
of it's a very effective dance for some
years now today we'll be looking
specifically how to harness put on all
size PC piece ok for which this actually
will start the next lecture with
accounting we will make sure that the
parameters make sense and then we'll get
into their security reduction
full assumption of collision resistance
or is it has there been you know how
things work that's living somewhere
saying like because right like
deliciousness and say it's did me any
collision but it's not clear from any
collision hard breakfast protocol right
I need a collision on to be CPS a true
part of these fees or any other
collision them two outputs attaches is
they like in the random Oracle well
maybe you know some way to it's a great
question I'm not aware of progress in a
direction more generally you can ask
kinda one construct sixteenth arguments
on one-way functions and I'm not aware
of forests they are either positively or
negatively
maybe you good we can we can relax this
multi collision resistance thank you and
what they will do it will help you I
think with around somewhere and it can
relax it there but further like a
different style of assumption that's not
missus that's a strict relaxation yeah
they actually show some kind of like
gradual way of moving from one it
functions to create resistance yeah this
resistance there every more multi gives
you more power by starting from oh my
functions foreclose me that's in terms
of the assumption the police
yeah MCH is an actual relaxation and if
you assume collision resistance North
treason
as far as yeah so I think that would be
very nice yeah but that does are
structured like things like this you
actually you can instead of thinking
about constructing something out of just
a plain ch
you can just try to formulate what was
the miracle tree doing for me well you
know I was committing to a vector and I
was revealing certain positions of the
vector and you know as dan was pointing
out you can use a number of accumulators
based on different number aesthetic
assumptions that will can replace
entirely the miracle tree with you know
suitable accumulator and then you get a
different trade-offs in particular
you're able to circumvent this issue of
a logarithmic size authentication paths
we should you both asymptotically and
concretely you know contribute to proof
size
so I think it's a good time to stop also
because it is time to stop and let's
resume at 11:00
[Applause]